they're saying that we should destroy
the federal reserve's independence in
order to save joe biden but what they
really mean is that joe biden is
incredibly bad at this job so what this
means is that joe biden now has to rely
on a secondary message for 2022 and so
do the democrats that secondary message
is republicans are trying to stymie the
vote okay this is all crazy talk if they
think this is going to work they're
crazy first of all more democrats voted
in the last election cycle than in any
election cycle in american history and
it is not close the turnout rates were
extraordinary joe biden won 81 million
votes okay those are big numbers
if there's election stifling going on
there is no evidence that there's
election stifling going on there's less
evidence that people are being kept from
voting in the united states and that
people are engaging in widespread voter
fraud less evidence okay so for all the
people on the left you keep saying that
donald trump is propagating the big lie
by talking about electoral fraud and
that in the notion that he won the 2020
election
it is a much bigger lie when you suggest
that there are millions of people being
disenfranchised at the ballot box that
is just a lie it is not true at all and
yet this is what democrats are relying
upon
so nancy pelosi goes the furthest she
basically makes the argument that
conservatives republicans they ought to
be treated like terrorists she says
january 6 with a terror attack and then
she also says
that republicans in the states who are
pursuing voter verification methods they
are just a continuation of the terror
attacks of january 6. basically you're
all terrorists i i do have to note here
that whoever is doing nancy pelosi's
botox needs to be stopped
someone needs to be stopped here she has
gone full jack nicholson joker fell
directly into the vat of toxic waste i
don't know what's going on here now
those of us who suffer from a family
receding hairline i've never seen before
receding eyebrows that is a new one her
eyebrows are literally receding all the
way up her face
they started off just above her eyes and
now they're halfway up her forehead and
if she continues in this manner her
eyebrows will eventually be all the way
at the back of her head
she'll be talking you'll just see her
eyebrows wiggling all the way up here i
don't know what's going on like these
are the people who run our country
here is nancy pelosi crazy nancy pelosi
who looks like
a a marionette like an edgar berg and
marionette talking about how you are
basically a terrorist if you support
voter id
there's nothing more important for us to
do
than protect our constitution and our
democracy what the republicans are doing
across the country is really a a
legislative
continuation of what they did on january
6 which is to undermine our democracy
it's a legislative continuation of
january 6 undermining our democracy is
the line
so this is the line they're going to
carry into 2022 good luck with this
you've got bad inflation you've got bad
coveted policy you've got
underemployment because not enough
people are getting back into the labor
force
you have a completely failed foreign
policy and nancy pelosi's pitch is that
everybody who is pushing voter id in
states like georgia was complicit in
january 6th
really good luck with this and then
trotting out maxine waters to back this
my goodness you guys have a very very
weak pitch or is maxine waters doing the
same thing last night
this is not something that they have any
real issues about relative to how the
system is working whether it's this that
or the other this is about racism
this is about exclusion this is about
not wanting us to be able uh to
participate in the policies that govern
this country
it's about racism and exclusion and uh
and also you should confront people you
don't like in parking lots and scream at
them
also i i will admit that that i was not
expecting the john lennon
1980s style so like john lennon was dead
by that point but um if he had blown up
those sunglasses the crazy sunglasses
made them very large and plunked them
down on maxine waters that would have
been the look this is great by the way
chuck schumer is trying to force a vote
on the filibuster like this is how
desperate they are he's now
demonstrating his own incompetence he's
demonstrating full skill his own
incompetence
the senate majority leader is going to
try to vote on the filibuster and see if
kristin cinema in arizona and joe
manchin are going to kill the filibuster
on behalf of voting rights bill that
does not have majority support
good luck with that and then what's he
going to claim what is biden going to
claim what schumer going to claim has
been obstructed by republicans when he
can't even get his own democrats on
board
seriously they are so incompetent and
they are so boxed in and 20 22 is going
to be so ugly for them until they are
left merely with dreams of universal
health care and a hatred for those who
don't think like them if that's your
pitch you're going to get skunked come
november
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video